a new report finds a dog in North  Carolina has tested positive for Koba 19  this pug his name is Winston is believed  to be the first dog in the country to be  diagnosed he was tested as part of a  study at Duke University after his  owners contracted the virus  they say the dog was coughing and  sneezing and one day didn't want to eat  his breakfast  Winston recovered after a few days of  being sick his mom and dad say he's  doing better health-wise but they  haven't tested him again so they're not  sure that he's corona virus free of  course the Centers for Disease Control  says the risk of animal to human  transmission is low Gale important  reminder yeah yeah I'm looking at  Winston to be such a little guy he has a  very big tough tongue and it's the dog  didn't give it to the family the family  gave it to the dog so Winston's going  Thank You family thank you we send in  the family